did for you as like a white person
who grew up situated
as a white person no no the point i was
trying to make is how did it feel going
from like
eating rice every now and again to
eating rice for almost every meal
because i've had i've had a conversation
with people who you know grow up grew up
in america grew up in india
they've moved to an asian country and
i'm like man i really liked it at first
and then
i just got bored of eating rice for like
every meal
but i grew up with this [ __ ] so i'm used
to it yeah i mean it wears you down a
little bit but i feel like you really do
get used to it i don't know maybe maybe
some people it's like they like it at
first like you said they start to hate
it but for me it was like
i don't know rice has just always been
there it's like bread but in a different
format for me
yeah it's like
if brett is the hard drive then rice is
the sd card
it's like they all do the same thing
they just fill you up in their carbs
right yeah
i i think most of the time here it's
not just plain rice sometimes it is like
when you go to ryokan yeah it's just
like plain [ __ ] rice in it
and it's so starchy and sticky like [ __ ]
dude my
i'm eating [ __ ] play-doh here but
you know when you go like my favorite
place in the world matzia
you know i'm like here we go again i
must look like a freak when i do this
right
so when they cook the the pork pork by
the way god not beef bees like [ __ ] yeah
um
they they cook the pork right there's
like juices right
normally you just kind of like pick up
the pork and put in the rice
put some mayo on it and then eat it yeah
i [ __ ] like
in the restaurant i'm like hold up my
plate and like pour all like the the
fats and stuff
on the rice i don't know i can agree
yeah that tastes so
[ __ ] good dude because it makes it so
rich but it's just
the [ __ ] audacity to go into a beef
ball place and order pork
this guy okay this guy honestly you go
matsuya man i'm telling you man that
that pork and ginger
oh no i've had it yeah yeah it's great
yeah we're gonna smash one time
but it's like vanilla beef why would i
have a vanilla beef are you out of your
mind
don't start this again vanilla
beef really oh my god man like i would
definitely if i walk into a martial i'm
ordering a beef ball
it's beef without attitude yeah what can
i say that has pork yeah that's poor
yeah okay
this is going to be like the biggest
comment war in the comments section
out of like any shitty opinion we have
mainly americans watching us and i feel
that americans will side with beef
because like beef is way more prevalent
and they're right
no no they're not right guys they're not
right
you know what's an underrated meat lamb
is pretty [ __ ] good
lambs okay here's the thing about lamb
is that it has to be like
really good quality yeah because if
you're like
the aftertaste and lamb can be so
overpowering
yeah it just it just tastes like hot
yeah lamb [ __ ] sucks here bro yeah
yeah sometimes
leather it's like eating leather
essentially yeah we went to a restaurant
once man and it was like a roulette
wheel on this lamb
for some reason some of these lamb chops
were like perfectly cooked yeah you had
another one
it's like trying to look like a man
yeah it's like when do i just swallow
and give up right when do i just admit
like i had a cheerleader jawline
by the way because from all the [ __ ]
chewing i was doing it's like either my
jaw dislocates you or like i'm done
well i'm choking on this [ __ ] entire
piece of land yeah there's just some
meats like that and especially coming
from wales where like yeah you know
they [ __ ] sheep that's the stereotype
right that's what everyone does i mean
lamb is [ __ ] great you're a great
lamb